des enfants pleine santé qui font de
graff d'hépatite des transplantations
des cas qui s'accumulent les grandes
agences de santé publique lève le
drapeau jaune un nouveau problème est
apparu sur le radar des investigations à
hong hong et
reporting à six pattes est presque exact
cros
patrice romain
la maladie parfois fulgurante la jeune
britannique lola rose un plein format 3
1 a failli mourir en l'espace de
quelques semaines c'est la
transplantation d'une partie du foie de
son père alain rinne qui l'a sauvé
jusqu'ici on a rapporté 190 cas
d'hépatites de ce genre dans une
douzaine de pays presque 10% des enfants
ont dû subir une transplantation
au canada la santé publique enquête sur
plusieurs cas d'hépatites aiguës
d'origine inconnue chez des jeunes mais
sans donner plus de précisions c'est peu
un chiffre absolu mais suffisant pour
inquiéter les spécialistes il semblait
vraiment qu'il ya un signal qui nous
indique quelque chose de différent est
en train de se passer et on voit une
augmentation du nombre de cas d'hépatite
l'hypothèse la plus étudiée une souche
d'aider nos virus un virus commun
souvent associé un simple rhume 1 75 %
des enfants on est à porter mais on est
loin d'une certitude le premier pas
c'est justement s il cherchait le plus
d'informations possible et pour en faire
ça il faut que les cliniciens à travers
le monde soit conscient du problème
potentiel afin de pouvoir rapporter les
cas un autre coupable possible mais
indirecte la pandémie pense aussi qu est
les faits qui est laissée enfin surtout
les enfants les plus jeunes n'ont pas
été aussi exposés à différents virus
incluant des sardines au virus
respiratoires delà des dernières années
et ça facilite mais non l'apparition
d'autres villes aussi la circulation
d'autres virus selon les spécialistes
les parents devraient surveiller
l'apparition de certains symptômes comme
la gastro entérite un changement de
couleur des selles et d'urines ou une
forte fièvre la majorité des enfants
touchés avaient moins de 6 ans ici
normand grondin radio canada montréal